[Music]
let's take a look at Bitcoin right now
it's down just about one and a third
percent hovering above 29 100 bucks at
this hour as new developments break in
the Sam bankman free case the former FTX
CEO and disgraced crypto Kingpin is
facing jail time ahead of his highly
anticipated fraud trial in October after
a short stint in a Bahamas jail cell SPF
has so far dodged getting thrown back
behind bars as a federal judge evaluates
prosecutors demand to revoke his bail
they say he crossed a line by leaking
the Diary of his ex-girlfriend and star
witness in the trial Caroline Ellison to
the New York Times labeling the move
witness tampering the news comes as the
Department of Justice says it will not
pursue a campaign finance charge against
Sam begman freed the second charge now
against him that has been dropped since
the indictment because he donated a lot
to some politicians in Washington
joining me now discuss all of it is
pompliano Investments Anthony pompliano
he's here in a fox business exclusive
well give us your first reaction to the
SBF developments
yeah thanks so much for having me Liz um
look I think that we have to remember
that the United States is still uh the
land and where rule of law prevails and
what we've seen I think is uh there are
people who are working inside of each
one of these organizations to figure out
what happened what was legal what was it
legal and then they're going to go in
front of a court of law they're going to
present a case and ultimately that court
of law is going to decide what should
occur you know without getting into too
many of the details and trying to keep
up with every last individual
development I think that the court of
law is really important here in the
United States
and ultimately I think that it'll end up
serving Justice whatever that should end
up being based on facts sure innocent
until proven guilty but do you think
that investors or the Bitcoin or crypto
curious have looked beyond this sort of
shock of last November where it was like
whoa everybody seemed to have lost their
money some temporarily some they still
don't have it back but does it mean that
they're willing to look back intraday
Bitcoin doesn't look good but if you
stretch it out it has certainly come
well up off the high of the lows
yeah for sure if you you know a couple
of stats look at uh Bitcoin is up about
80 year to date it's up like 2x off the
bottom uh of what appears to have been
the bottoming of the bear Market uh if
you go all the way back in the pandemic
era Bitcoin is up over 300 pretty much
if you had bought Bitcoin rather than
invest in a hedge fund you would have
outperformed uh during that time period
and so I definitely think that that
shows people are coming back into the
market another great uh kind of data
point is that 74 of all Bitcoin in
circulation is being held by long-term
holders meaning that it's contributing
to this illiquid Supply so you have a
very illiquid market and on the horizon
you see BlackRock Fidelity and many
others trying to get these ETFs approved
and so it looks like a similar setup to
what we had in 2020 highly illiquid
market demand will come into the market
at the same time we're going to get a
having next year where the incoming
daily Supply will get cut in half and
just as we saw a very very aggressive
run-up in bitcoin's price from 2020 into
the beginning of 2021 I do think that
we're watching a similar setup here well
there are a whole bunch of organizations
and and companies trying and vying to be
the first to get that spot Bitcoin ETF
approved by the SEC and it's not just
BlackRock or Wisdom Tree it's Arc
Investments it's vanak they're all very
interested in getting in there what will
whoever gets it what will that approval
if it does come due for Bitcoin in your
opinion
yeah I mean it's just increased Demand
right and what we've seen in the
futures-based ETF that got approved is a
billion dollars flew into the product in
like 48 hours and so obviously there is
this pent-up demand now people should
remember that there are futures-based
ETFs and spot uh Bitcoin ETFs available
elsewhere around the world but the
American Capital markets are still King
and so I do think that once that ETF
gets approved a lot of capital will flow
into the product and so if you have an
increase in demand you have an illiquid
product uh or Market in Bitcoin the
price has to move to accommodate
everyone and so I think that you know
it's obvious to see the market set up
the timing is the hard part here when is
it going to happen your guess is as good
as mine uh let's talk about when is it
going to happen with xrp because of
course xrp has had an incredible run up
even as it's got the SEC breathing down
its neck it got a favorable judge ruling
uh Court ruling rather and we're waiting
to see if the SEC will appeal that that
ruling which basically was in in xrp
please favor
um right now it's at 71 cents where do
you think xrp uh moves toward through
all of this drama
yeah I'm not sure about prices what I do
know though is uh you had a group of
people who went ahead and they were
building a business Building Technology
the government came in and said hey look
what you're doing is wrong you're
violating these rules and they went to
court and I actually think that we are
now seeing cases that have been going on
for a long time where we're starting to
get some of the judgments we're starting
to get some of the clarity people in the
crypto Community have been asking for
regulatory Clarity for a long time
people in the regulatory bodies have
been saying the existing rules are the
clarity comply with them and so I think
in the xrp case it's a great example
where they went to court they laid out
their arguments the regulatory uh bodies
laid out their arguments and a
judgmented decision now there's appeals
and you know other kind of knock-on
effects But ultimately in the country of
the United States going to court and
making your case is part of what it
means to have the best 100 Freedom
absolutely uh part of part of the U.S
and and our laws is that Congress can
move to regulate things of actually the
Bitcoin and the crypto world has been
begging for guard rails to say let us
move forward and let us know the rules
of the road we now have six Democrats
joining Republicans when it comes to the
20 the fit for the 21st century act this
is the bill that lays out clear rules of
the road for crypto regulation uh does
this mean what a signal that we're
finally getting Clarity in the space
I think that education takes a long time
and what we're seeing now is politicians
have been working behind the scenes them
and their teams trying to understand
this technology trying to understand the
market there's a lot of people in the
crypto community that have also been
spending their time trying to educate
these people one of the key pieces for
America moving forward is we must invest
in Innovation we have to continue to
innovate there's this new movement
online that people are talking about
which is effective accelerationism and
the whole idea is how do we accelerate
develop how do we accelerate building
how do we continue to use free market
principles to push technology forward so
that we can use that technology to
create a better life for ourselves and I
think that what we're watching here in
terms of Congress and these politicians
is they're realizing we have people who
are entrepreneurs and technologists in
the United States who want to solve
problems using this new technology let's
clear our path so that they're able to
do that and ultimately I think it'll
serve as a net positive for both the
American economy and the society at
large pop
love having you on thank you very much
we like your personality absolutely